it's a u-turn that many will claim was
inevitable
after protests and threats of legal
action from the capital's local
authorities
all primary schools in london will now
close
for the start of the new term the
education secretary gavin williamson
told mps on wednesday that the majority
of primary schools
would open as planned on monday january
the 4th
but he named 50 education authorities in
the south of england
including 22 of london's 32 boroughs
where covert infection rates were
highest he said
and whose primary schools will be closed
to most pupils
for the first two weeks of term we'll be
seeing
uh over 85 percent of primary schools
opening on the fourth of january
uh we want to see those schools that
uh are sadly not able to open on before
for january
to be opening at the earliest possible
moment
but the government's list included some
boroughs where transmission rates are
relatively low
and omitted others where the rates are
high
now primary schools in all 32 london
boroughs will be closed
to all but vulnerable children and those
of critical workers
myself a number of council leaders
across london have been
extremely confused by wednesday's
statement which didn't make sense to any
of us based on
the decisions and the data that was
published so we're absolutely delighted
that finally the government have
listened because
this is the right decision for our
children families and schools tonight
government sources have told sky news
that ministers have listened to the
concerns
raised by council leaders and public
health officials
and have responded mr williamson said
children's education and well-being
remains a national priority
moving further parts of london to remote
education
really is a last resort and a temporary
solution
as infection rates rise across the
country and particularly in london
we must make this move to protect our
country and the nhs
we'll continue to keep the list of local
authorities under review
and reopen classrooms as soon as we
possibly can
the decision has been backed by the
health secretary matt hancock
who says infections have risen sharply
across london over the past week
hospitals are coming under increased
pressure and the situation continues to
worsen
the government's move has been welcomed
though by london's mayor sadiq khan
who said it's good news that the
government has finally seen sense
and announced this u-turn the
government's original decision was
ridiculous
and has been causing immense confusion
for parents
teachers and staff across the capital
it's right that all schools in london
are treated the same
and that no primary schools in london
will be forced to open on monday
but the decision is a further blow to
boris johnson's determination
to see schools reopen as planned
although the government insists the
decision is a response
to covet rates rising more rapidly mr
williamson will face
claims that he made the wrong decision
earlier this week
john craig sky news